this is a Ukrainian Village of nietzny
Sir Jose in the occupied herkson region
in October 2022 and in March 2023 the
new lines in the fields are rows of
Russian fortifications built in
anticipation of a counter-offensive by
Ukraine
while Kiev has been training its troops
to use Western weapons Russia has been
building some of the most extensive
defensive lines seen anywhere in the
world in decades according to Western
intelligence
my military analyst has spoke to the
Wall Street journals say they're
skeptical of the effectiveness of these
defenses the journal analyzed satellite
images and videos from Russian media to
understand what moscow's preparations
could mean for Ukraine
since the start of the invasion Russia
has been digging along the 900 mile
front line and even on its own territory
much of the work is focused on the
occupied areas of the zaparisha and her
son regions according to data collected
by a satellite image analyst British
intelligence say Russia has built 75
miles of defensive lines in separation
this hints are where Russia expects to
be attacked by Ukraine and many Western
analysts agree that these territories
could be the main targets of Ukraine's
counter-offensive
so here's what Russia has been building
the first layer of Defense shown in many
satellite images is the anti-tank ditch
the obstacle is meant to be too wide for
a tank to cross restricting an enemy's
ability to maneuver and funnel their
forces into areas that make them more
vulnerable to attack
next a rows of concrete blocks called
Dragon's Teeth they form a barrier that
makes it difficult for heavy vehicles to
pass through and the third line is a
trench this is the most common type of
defensive work and the easiest to
construct Russian forces dug many
trenches along roads Junctions and
bridges and even on the beaches of
Crimea
most of them were built at a zigzag or
angular pattern this limits sight lines
for the enemy and offers additional
protection from Shell fragments coming
from the side
and Ukrainian forces are likely to face
further traps military analysts believe
land mines have also been hidden between
defensive lines
Ukraine's and Russia's ministries of
Defense didn't respond to our requests
for comments on the significance of
moscow's fortification efforts
some military experts say these defense
systems don't necessarily pose a major
threat to the ukrainians they say
whether the fortifications are effective
would depend on the number of Russian
troops defending them and if Ukraine
attacks defensive lines that aren't
sufficiently protected the ukrainians
will be able to bypass the obstacles
with Western Challenger and leopard
battle tanks experts say that in the end
Intelligence on the position of Russian
troops will be key to Ukraine's
counter-offensive and whether they can
force Russia to concentrate troops in
the wrong place and leave defensive
lines exposed
foreign